holding up the three-finger salute
that's become a symbol of resistance in
myanmar
the soldier looks towards the country
he's left behind
we've chosen not to reveal his identity
he says he fled his military camp in
myanmar after weeks of being ordered
to shoot at protesters
i can no longer tolerate killing my own
people innocent people
i did not want to hurt them anymore the
main reason was i did not support the
military regime i hate the hunter
the former soldier is one of many army
and police officers from myanmar
who are taking refuge in the
northeastern indian border state of
mizoram
at least 400 people are thought to have
crossed the poorest border into the town
of champaign in the past three weeks
they're being looked after by locals
many of them came with no money some of
them were families
the needs of these refugees were
provided by the church youth
associations
the ngos a student leader helping the
new arrival says most people seeking
shelter in mizoram belong to the qin
ethnic group
and have close ties with people here the
brotherhood between the people of
myanmar
burma and mizoram starts even before
burma india got independence
and as such no single notification
restrictions or instruction could
make a wall between the brotherhood of
the myanmar and mizoram
the indian government has ordered the
four north eastern states bordering
myanmar to immediately identify and
deport
what it calls illegal migrants the
soldier who says he walked for two weeks
to reach mizoram told us
that would be a death sentence i think
they'll shoot me in the head
they'll execute me mizoram's leader
agrees
chief minister zoram tanga has told
prime minister narendra modi
india can't ignore what he called the
humanitarian crisis
unfolding in our own backyard given the
historical ties between the people of
mizoram and myanmar
it appears some have chosen to resist
the central government's orders
elizabeth puranam al jazeera new delhi